- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Bonjour à
tous.
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
Je vous rappelle, pour la bonne
compréhension de nos débats, que
les temps de parole sont limités à
deux minutes par intervenant.
Les questions et les réponses.
Pour la bonne compréhension des
téléspectateurs, nous avons inséré
un chronomètre sur la
retransmission télé.
Certains s'étonnaient que les
prises de parole étaient coupées.
C'est deux minutes pour tout le
monde.
J'espère que vous respecterez
cette règle comme d'habitude.
La première question va être posée
par monsieur Hubert Wulfranc.
- Hubert Wulfranc: Madame la
présidente, permettez-moi de dire
solennellement toute ma solidarité
avec la levée du collège Lecanuet
à Rouen, un élève mutilé d'un
doigt suite aux tirs d'une grenade
de désencerclement durant la
manifestation du 23 mars.
A son image, que toutes les
victimes de violences, d'où
qu'elles viennent, reçoivent tout
le soutien auquel elles ont droit.
Madame la Première ministre, cette
interpellation n'est pas une
question d'actualité au
gouvernement.
Le groupe GDR et les députés
communistes n'attendent pas de
réponse d'un gouvernement qui
refuse de répondre aux Français et
qui méconnaît l'actualité sociale.
Le groupe GDR n'attend pas de
réponse d'un gouvernement qui n'a
pas l'intérêt général comme une
boussole.
Le groupe GDR n'attend pas de
réponse du gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron face à cette
interpellation.
Son interpellation s'adresse à nos
concitoyens.
Désirez-vous un référendum sur les
retraites pour sortir le pays de
l'impasse, dans lequel un certain
gouvernement l'a piégé?
Si oui, faites grandir cette
exigence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt, ministre du Travail, du
Plein emploi et de l'Insertion.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Ca n'était donc pas votre
question.
Ca n'est pas votre question, mais
ça sera la réponse de celle du
gouvernement pour vous dire que
lorsque vous dites, quand vous
prétendez que ce gouvernement ne
souhaite la Concorde ni la
réussite.
Avec cette réforme des retraites,
nous avons l'objectif de garantir
un système par répartition, faire
en sorte que ce système de
retraite puisse perdurer.
Je pense que vous partagerez ce
point avec moi.
Je n'ai aucune inquiétude.
Nos concitoyens sauront toujours
s'en sortir.
Ce qui m'intéresse, ce sont ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens de
préparer l'avenir.
C'est pour eux que nous faisons ce
système de retraite.
La réforme que nous portons permet
de conserver un système de
retraite qui leur permettra, aux
plus fragiles, d'avoir un revenu
décent une fois l'heure du repos
arrivée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Allez-y, mon
cher collègue.
- Hubert Wulfranc: Madame la
présidente, les propos du groupe
GDR n'appelaient aucune réponse du
gouvernement.
La seule réponse qui vaille pour
nous, désormais, c'est le vote des
Français.
Seul dénouement démocratique dont
nous ne doutons pas qu'il
sanctionne le retrait de cette
réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Marie Fiévet pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Jean-Marie Fiévet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
Ce samedi 25 mars, à
Sainte-Soline, nos forces de
l'ordre ont été la cible de
plusieurs milliers d'individus
radicaux et violents.
C'était une manifestation non
autorisée et ils étaient
armés de cocktails Molotov, de
mortiers, de haches et de
projectiles dangereux.
C'est le résultat d'une tristesse
accablante.
Nous avons assisté à des scènes
d'affrontement choquantes au cours
desquelles des véhicules de forces
de l'ordre ont été incendiés et de
nombreuses personnes ont été
blessées.
Au nom du groupe Renaissance, je
tiens à souhaiter un bon
rétablissement à tous les blessés,
ainsi qu'à apporter nos soutiens à
nos forces de l'ordre pour leur
engagement.
J'ai aussi une pensée pour les
pompiers des Deux-Sèvres et pour
le SAMU, pour les agriculteurs,
qui subissent des dégradations et
des menaces depuis plusieurs mois.
Face à ces images intolérables, et
à l'inverse des élus de la NUPES,
présents aux manifestations, qui
se réjouissent du désordre social
au point de lancer des fake news,
jusqu'à annoncer la mort d'un
manifestant, j'en appelle à
l'apaisement et à la raison.
N'en déplaise à certains, notre
démocratie prévoit le droit aux
opposants de manifester
pacifiquement, mais en aucun cas
l'usage de la violence.
Monsieur le ministre,
pourriez-vous nous indiquer quelle
mesure vous allez prendre face à
ces menaces inacceptables?
De tels affrontements ne peuvent
et ne doivent se reproduire.
La manifestation était interdite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée
pour le maréchal des logis du GIGN
mort en mission voilà quelques
jours.
Applaudissements
Merci pour lui, pour le GIGN et
pour sa famille.
Monsieur le député, vous
m'interrogez.
Dans votre département se sont
passés des événements
inqualifiables.
La préfète des Deux-Sèvres avait
interdit la manifestation à
Sainte-Soline et aux abords de la
ville.
Chacun connaissait cette
interdiction de manifestation.
Nous savions depuis le premier
événement, qui avait déjà fait
naître 61 gendarmes blessés, qu'il
y avait des violences
inacceptables contre les biens et
surtout contre les personnes.
Evidemment, les militaires de la
gendarmerie et plusieurs
manifestants ont été blessés.
Je veux avoir une pensée pour ceux
qui luttent pour la vie en ce
moment et pour les blessés.
Je veux dire, évidemment, notre
compassion à chacune et chacun.
Aucune cause ne peut justifier ces
violences.
Cependant, je constate comme vous
l'extrême violence de certains
groupuscules dont les services de
renseignement démontrent qu'ils
sont fichés parfois depuis de
nombreuses années et qui sont
responsables d'une grande
violence.
Plusieurs envahissent en
entreprise, plusieurs actions
fortes contre les forces de
l'ordre,
plusieurs destructions de biens,
des centaines de gendarmes et de
policiers blessés, plusieurs
appels à l'insurrection...
J'ai donc décidé d'engager une
dissolution.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Laurent
Jacobelli pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Laurent Jacobelli: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Comme à chaque fois, ils ont
cassé, tabassé, incendié et
agressé nos forces de l'ordre
selon un scénario aujourd'hui bien
connu.
Il y avait parmi eux un fiché S.
Vous savez pertinemment qui ils
sont, où ils habitent, elles ont
leur mode d'action.
Vous avez toutes les clés en main
pour leurs empêcher de nuire.
Pourtant, ils sont libres et ils
continuent à semer le chaos.
Peut-être cette violence de
l'ultra gauche vous permet-elle de
détourner l'attention de la
politique du gouvernement.
En attaquant par le mal à la
racine, vous laissez prospérer la
mauvaise herbe.
Cette ultra gauche est toujours
plus armée, plus violente, mieux
organisée et désormais
internationalisée.
Elle communique en toute liberté
sur les réseaux sociaux et elle
recrute.
Ce sont de véritables milices
armées qui sont en formation dans
notre pays.
Depuis des années, nous alertons
avec Marine Le Pen contre
l'escalade de cette mouvance.
Si nous n'y prenons garde, à ce
rythme-là, nous vivrons peut-être
bientôt sous la menace de
nouvelles années de plomb.
Dans cette escalade de la
violence, nous risquons de voir
apparaître les successeurs des
Brigades rouges ou d'Action
directe, avec cette fois comme
prétexte la protection de
l'environnement.
Agissez, monsieur le ministre.
Pouvez-vous nous dire ici quelles
sont les mesures que vous comptez
mettre en place pour éradiquer ces
milices d'extrême gauche avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, je vais
répondre à votre question.
Je regrette que vous n'ayez pas eu
un mot pour les policiers et les
gendarmes blessés.
Avant ces événements, vos prises
de parole publiques ont été assez
défavorables contre la police sur
les plateaux de télévision.
Je serai prêt à vous donner
quelques extraits.
Je vous encourage à ne pas
soutenir la police quand ça vous
arrange.
Il y a chez les policiers et chez
les gendarmes des femmes et des
hommes de toutes opinions
politiques qui nous protègent.
N'ayez pas le soutien de la police
sélectif.
Vous avez raison, monsieur le
député.
Il y a des militants extrémistes
dans notre pays.
Il y en a beaucoup de l'ultra
gauche et il y en a beaucoup de
l'ultra droite.
Nous aimerions que vous les
condamniez de la même manière.
Il y a des personnes qui sont
fichées S dans notre pays.
Vous avez raison, mais je vais
vous rappeler qu'un fichier de
renseignements n'est pas une
incrimination pénale.
Je constate que le gouvernement,
lorsqu'il y avait un autre
ministre de l'Intérieur que vous
avez combattu, a été censuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel, et
vous n'avez pas voté le texte
qu'il vous avait proposé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
Mon cher collègue?
- Laurent Jacobelli: J'aimerais
que vous ayez la virulence quand
il s'agit d'attaquer les milices
d'extrême gauche que quand vous
attaquez l'opposition
parlementaire et démocratique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin: Je pense que
vous avez fait une sorte de lapsus
intellectuel.
Je n'ai pas parlé du Rassemblement
National quand je parlais de
l'ultra droite.
Si vous vous sentez visé, j'en
suis désolé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Ciotti pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Eric Ciotti: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Depuis plusieurs semaines, des
millions de Français manifestent
calmement, encadrés de façon
responsable par les organisations
syndicales.
Malheureusement, dans ces
cortèges, se sont glissés des
militants d'extrême gauche dont le
seul objectif est de piller, de
brûler, de tuer du flic.
Dans ce contexte, nos policiers et
nos gendarmes se trouvent en
première ligne.
Plus de 500 d'entre eux ont été
blessés.
A l'occasion de la manifestation
de jeudi dernier et samedi.
500 policiers ou gendarmes qui
garantissent l'ordre républicain.
Nous leur devons une
reconnaissance.
Nous leur devons un hommage
républicain pour leur dire que
sans eux, la République ne
tiendrait pas.
Applaudissements nourris
...
Les policiers, mais sans surprise,
constateront que sur les bancs de
l'extrême gauche, cet hommage
n'est pas accepté.
Et vous refusez de vous y
associer, comme madame Panot, ce
matin, qui indiquait de façon
scandaleuse qu'un manifestant
était mort, instrumentalisant ce
conflit social a des visées
extrémistes!
Alors oui, je le dis, nous
demandons, dans ce contexte, des
mesures fortes.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur vient
d'en parler, mais cela ne suffit
pas.
Les mots ne suffisent plus.
Il faut des actes.
Il faut des actes concrets.
Ces individus, ces milices
d'extrême gauche, sont connues.
Il faut aujourd'hui les éradiquer.
Il faut changer de cadre.
Je veux également dénoncer avec
force les propos honteux de
monsieur Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
appelant à faire soigner les
policiers, sans doute dans les
camps de rééducation qui existent
dans les pays dictatoriaux...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président Eric Ciotti,
merci pour les mots que vous avez
eu pour les policiers et pour les
gendarmes.
Je veux aussi penser aux
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été pris
à partie encore ce matin dans
l'ouest de la France.
Je veux souligner, monsieur le
député Ciotti, que les préfets de
la république, les policiers et
les gendarmes, et les
organisations syndicales, ont su
organiser les huit grandes
journées de manifestations contre
la réforme des retraites sans
qu'il n'y ait aucun incident
majeur dans notre pays, avec des
millions de personnes partout sur
le territoire national.
Des millions cumulés, madame la
présidente Le Pen, ne vous
inquiétez pas.
Lorsque l'extrême gauche et
l'ultra gauche s'est mêlée aux
manifestations sauvages non
déclarées, s'attaquant aux
syndicaux, aux policiers et aux
gendarmes, à des préfectures, à
des commissariats, à des hôpitaux,
à des tribunaux, à des permanences
politiques et des parlementaires,
menaçant les élus de la
république, alors oui, le chaos
cherche à s'installer.
Ce que je regrette comme vous,
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas
d'unanimité dans la classe
politique pour dénoncer ces
groupes factieux qui veulent
mettre à bas la république.
L'ultra gauche ne veut pas
attaquer la réforme des retraites.
Elle veut attaquer la République!
L'ultra gauche ne veut pas
attaquer le gouvernement.
Elle veut attaquer les policiers!
Et ça fait huit groupuscules ou
associations d'extrêmes gauches
que je propose à dissolution,
toutes validées par le Conseil
d'Etat.
Nous continuerons grâce aux
services de renseignement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur François
Jolivet pour le groupe Horizons.
- François Jolivet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mes chers collègues, le groupe
tient d'abord et avant tout à
rendre un hommage au gendarme papa
de deux enfants qui a été tué.
441, c'est le nombre de policiers
et gendarmes qui ont été blessés
en France lors des manifestations
de ces dernières semaines.
A cela s'ajoutent 47 gendarmes
blessés le week-end dernier lors
de l'opération de sécurisation et
de maintien de l'ordre d'une
manifestation interdite à
Sainte-Soline.
Je ne peux pas ne pas penser non
plus aux deux manifestants qui
luttent pour leur vie
et, chers collègues, les forces de
l'ordre exercent leur mission,
celle d'assurer la sécurité des
personnes et des biens.
Je tiens à saluer l'engagement de
ces femmes et de ces hommes qui
consacrent leur vie
professionnelle à la protection de
leurs concitoyens.
Loin de moi l'idée de mettre sur
le même plan des manifestations
sécurisées et l'émergence de
groupes, de casseurs,
d'extrémistes et autres blacks
blocs venus pour générer de la
violence contre nos institutions
et leurs représentants.
A Paris comme ailleurs, des
manifestations se transforment et
tombent dans l'illégalité.
Absence de déclaration préalable,
absence d'itinéraire, absence de
service d'ordre...
Tout contribue à une escalade de
violence illégitime, incomprise
par les Français et porteuse d'un
seul message.
Comment assurer dans ces
conditions une politique de
maintien de l'ordre adaptée qui
concilie liberté de manifester et
sécurité des personnes et des
biens?
De quels moyens le ministre de
l'Intérieur dispose-t-il pour
empêcher que des manifestations
pacifistes ne le soient plus?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, je veux vous remercier,
comme certains de vos collègues
l'ont fait, pour le soutien que
vous apportez aux forces de
l'ordre.
En ce qui concerne Sainte-Soline,
le gouvernement n'a rien à cacher.
J'ai donc demandé deux rapports,
qui ont été élaborés jusqu'à ce
matin.
Je les mettrai en ligne cet
après-midi sur le site du
ministère de l'Intérieur.
Je suis à la disposition de toutes
et tous pour répondre aux
interrogations de la
représentation nationale.
Je veux par ailleurs dire que lors
de ces manifestations, évidemment,
les manifestations déclarées, le
devoir des policiers et des
gendarmes est de permettre de
manifester.
C'est le premier honneur des
policiers et des gendarmes.
Et ils le font de façon répétée
dans toutes les villes de France
avec calme et dignité.
Je veux dire ici que la confiance
absolue et le soutien total que
j'ai envers les forces de l'ordre
depuis trois ans que je suis
ministre n'empêche pas d'avoir la
même exigence dans le respect de
la déontologie et que s'il devait
y avoir des policiers et des
gendarmes qui ne respectent pas le
droit, ils seront évidemment
sanctionnés.
Je veux dire qu'il nous manque
trois choses pour répondre à votre
question.
Il y a de plus en plus de forces
de l'ordre et d'unités de forces
mobiles.
Vous nous l'accordez par la loi de
programmation votée dans cet
hémicycle et je vous en remercie.
La deuxième des choses, ce sont
des images.
Pour des raisons complexes, la
police et la gendarmerie sont les
seules à ne pas pouvoir faire
voler des drones en France.
Bientôt, le décret qui sortira de
la loi de la sécurité globale
permettra à la police et à la
gendarmerie d'avoir des drones
quand les casseurs en auront à
Sainte-Soline.
Troisièmement, il faut continuer
notre attaque contre l'extrême
gauche.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Clémentine
Autain pour le groupe LFI.
- Clémentine Autain: Madame la
Première ministre, combien de
temps encore allez-vous écraser la
démocratie de tout le poids de vos
49.3, de tout le choc de vos
matraques, de tout le mépris d'une
poignée qui décide, enfermée dans
son monde?
Nous avons fait la réforme des
retraites que les Français
attendaient.
Vous avez osé affirmer ceci.
Vous prétendez vouloir apaiser.
Vous alimentez chaque jour le
chaudron de la colère.
Vous vous croyez dans votre bon
droit, vous jouez d'une confusion
entre la légalité et la
démocratie.
Ce que les Français attendent, et
vous le savez, c'est le retrait de
votre projet.
Les organisations syndicales,
exemplairement unies contre vous,
l'exigent depuis des mois.
7 Français sur 10 n'en veulent
pas.
90% des salariés le rejettent.
Ils font grève.
Ils bloquent.
Ils pétitionnent.
Mais devant un tel déferlement que
nous n'avons pas connu depuis
1968, mes chers collègues,
visiblement, le gouvernement, le
président de la République, ont
perdu toute connexion au monde
réel et toute humanité devant le
sourd du pays que vous enchaînez.
C'est foudroyant pour la
démocratie.
Mais votre stratégie du
pourrissement, de l'intimidation,
de la tension permanente ne cesse
d'échouer.
Elle échoue parce que notre pays
renoue avec une histoire que vous
méprisez, celle de l'irruption de
ceux qui ne sont rien, celle de la
foule...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt, ministre du Travail, du
Plein emploi et de l'Insertion.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée Clémentine Autain...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Non, vous
étiez à deux minutes cinq.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous confondez
votre chronomètre avec le mien.
Madame la députée, alimentez le
chaudron de la colère, opposez la
légitimité de la rue à celle de la
démocratie parlementaire...
Il aurait suffi que vous ajoutiez:
bloquer le fondement de
l'assemblée par votre obstruction.
En réalité, votre interpellation,
c'est l'accusation négative de ce
que vous faites et de ce que vous
nourrissez.
Vous nous dites de retirer la
réforme.
Dites-le aux femmes à qui nous
allons relever les pensions.
Dites-le aux salariés qui sont
exposés aux métiers les plus
pénibles et pour lesquels nous
avons amélioré la prise en compte
de la pénibilité.
Dites-le à toutes les femmes pour
lesquelles nous allons faire en
sorte d'intégrer des trimestres de
congé parental, des trimestres
passés à aider leurs proches.
Madame la députée, quand vous
dites de retirer la réforme, vous
enlevez les droits aux Français.
Votre objectif est un objectif de
chaos.
Vous ne souhaitez qu'une chose,
c'est que la misère prospère.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole
est à monsieur Benjamin
Saint-Huile.
- Benjamin Sainte-Huile: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mes chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Vous dites vouloir apaiser, et
pourtant, vous ne faites aucun
geste et aucun pas vers ceux qui
vous tendent la main.
Le président de la République a
évoqué la semaine dernière une
colère légitime.
Et pourtant, il est resté prostré
dans son arrogance.
Les Français, l'intersyndicale,
les manifestants, les oppositions,
ne vous demandent qu'une chose:
suspendre ou retirer cette
réforme.
Depuis l'utilisation improvisée du
49.3, l'escalade de la tension
sociale est palpable partout dans
le pays.
Entre les manifestants méprisés,
les forces de l'ordre épuisées,
les groupes violents galvanisés,
les violences sont de plus en plus
nombreuses.
Nous condamnons avec la plus
grande fermeté ces violences.
Dans ce désordre, le gouvernement
a une responsabilité non
négligeable.
Madame la Première ministre, il
faut que cela cesse.
Il faut que cela s'arrête.
Vous ne pouvez pas, vous ne devez
pas faire le choix du
pourrissement par tactique
politicienne.
Nous voulons le retour à la paix,
le retour au calme.
Madame la Première ministre, avec
humilité, saisissez la main de
ceux qui prônent le dialogue, le
respect et le compromis, suspendez
cette réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt:
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Benjamin
Saint-Huile, je ne reviendrai pas
sur la totalité du débat.
L'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
ont débattu pendant 175 heures de
la réforme des retraites.
Celle-ci a fait l'objet de quatre
mois de concertation.
Le débat parlementaire a permis
d'améliorer encore le texte.
Il a permis de l'améliorer avec
une meilleure prise en compte des
carrières longues.
Il protège mieux les femmes qui
ont une carrière complète à 63
ans.
Il y a la prise en compte
d'améliorer des trimestres
d'apprentissage, la possibilité de
racheter plus facilement des
trimestres de stage ou d'études
supérieures.
Le texte qui a été adopté n'est
plus véritablement le texte du
gouvernement et il répond à nos
objectifs.
Aujourd'hui, ce texte va être mis
en oeuvre.
Il n'est pas possible de suspendre
un texte tel qu'il a été voté.
Vous nous appelez à reprendre le
dialogue.
La Première ministre a à nouveau
proposé à l'intersyndicale de les
rencontrer, de discuter, d'évoquer
les questions d'usure
professionnelle, les questions
relatives au déroulement des
carrières, de faire en sorte que
tous les sujets liés au travail
puissent être améliorés.
Nous avons cette volonté de débat
en faisant bien la différence
entre les organisations syndicales
avec lesquelles nous souhaitons
discuter et les émeutiers, les
factieux qui veulent mettre du
désordre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Benjamin Saint-Huile?
- Benjamin Sainte-Huile: Madame la
Première ministre, vous êtes une
femme d'Etat.
Vous avez la responsabilité qui
est la vôtre.
Madame la Première ministre, il
n'y a pas de déshonneur à
reconnaître une erreur.
Il n'y a pas de défaite à
reconnaître un échec.
La seule chose qui doit nous
guider, c'est l'intérêt de la
nation, l'intérêt des Françaises
et des Français.
En sagesse, pour permettre le
retour d'un débat serein, pour
permettre le dialogue avec tout le
monde, retirez cette réforme dès à
présent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Stéphanie
Rist.
- Stéphanie Rist: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
Début avril, devrait s'appliquer
la loi que nous avons votée en
2021 qui portait une mesure du
Ségur permettant de limiter
l'intérim médical excessif.
Il ne s'agit pas de l'interdire,
mais d'en limiter le recours de
manière exagérée.
Ca peut parfois dépasser les 4000
euros par jour.
Le plafond légal depuis 2016 est à
1162 euros par jour.
Ces situations sont inéquitables
et coûtent plus de 1,5 milliard
d'euros à l'Assurance maladie.
Comment certains médecins
hospitaliers peuvent tolérer qu'un
intérimaire gagne parfois son
salaire mensuel en 2 ou 3 jours?
L'application de la loi est
soutenue par les fédérations
hospitalières, les présidents de
commissions médicales et tant
d'autres.
En tant qu'élu, nous sommes
convaincus de la nécessité de
l'application de la loi.
Je veux relayer nos inquiétudes
face à la menace de fermeture de
certains services des hôpitaux de
nos régions.
La préservation de notre hôpital
public est un enjeu majeur pour
nous tous.
Nous devons le rendre plus
attractif.
Nous avons apporté une première
réponse avec le Ségur, mais nous
devons mieux valoriser les
professionnels engagés pour leur
établissement au bénéfice des
patients.
Comment valoriser mieux les
professionnels qui travaillent la
nuit et le week-end?
L'application de cette loi a été
retardée car elle nécessite un
travail en amont pour faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de risques
pour nos concitoyens et que les
mesures soient appliquées de façon
identique partout en France.
Pouvez-vous nous confirmer que la
mise en place de cette loi peut se
faire en toute sécurité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre de la
Santé.
- François Braun: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
j'entends les inquiétudes qui
montent des différents territoires
sur la mise en application de
cette loi.
Pour autant, il est indispensable
de la mettre en application, car
elle touche l'intérim médical qui
dérive complètement depuis trois
ans.
Les tarifs atteignent 5000 euros
pour 24 heures de garde.
C'est inacceptable.
Le nombre augmente également avec
plus de 80% d'augmentation ces
deux dernières années.
C'est en train de détruire notre
système hospitalier public.
C'est en train de faire partir les
médecins de l'hôpital public, qui
voient un praticien gagner en nuit
ou en deux, ce qu'ils gagnent en
un mois.
C'est nécessaire d'agir
rapidement.
Je tiens un compte précis avec
tous les services concernés.
Nous avons des solutions pour
avancer dans notre système de
santé, avec des gros hôpitaux et
des CHU qui viennent en soutien de
ces établissements.
Il faut agir sur les deux
tableaux: combattre cet intérim
cannibale, mais aussi revaloriser
les conditions de travail et le
statut des médecins hospitaliers.
Nous sommes en train de le faire.
Nous allons revaloriser la prime
de solidarité territoriale.
Nous parlons avec les syndicats
pour améliorer la pénibilité des
médecins.
Chaque territoire, nous lui
proposerons des solutions.
Tous les jours, les choses
évoluent.
Jusqu'au dernier moment, les ARS
et mon ministère feront en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de lacunes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Florence
Goulet.
- Florence Goulet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Dans une commune de moins de 3000
habitants de ma circonscription,
le groupe Ahlstrom a annoncé
l'intention de fermer son usine.
130 salariés sont concernés, sans
compter les familles.
Situation dramatique dans un
bassin où l'attractivité est en
souffrance et qui offre plus de
solutions de reclassement.
Dans cette usine, 77 employés ont
déjà fait l'objet d'un plan social
en 2019 sous prétexte de permettre
à l'usine d'investir dans l'outil
de production.
Les investissements n'ont pas eu
lieu.
C'est usine subit la concurrence
dans un contexte de crise
énergétique sans précédent.
La Meuse est un département très
éprouvé.
11 boulangeries ont fermé, en
raison de votre obstination à ne
pas sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité.
La plus ancienne et dernière
fabrique de poupées va fermer son
atelier, créé en 1860.
Dans le même temps, ce
gouvernement supprime des services
publics pourtant indispensables.
Pas moins de 18 classes seront
fermées à la prochaine rentrée
scolaire.
Hélas, lorsque l'on se retrouve au
chômage dans la Meuse, il ne
suffit pas de traverser la rue
pour retrouver un emploi.
Il y a un an, vous déclariez que
l'industrie française se portait
bien.
La semaine dernière, le président
se vantait encore que plus
d'entreprises étaient ouvertes que
fermées depuis qu'il était au
pouvoir.
Les salariés de cette entreprise
ont de la peine à voir ce constat.
Peut-être voyez-vous les choses
d'un peu trop loin.
Peut-être devez-vous venir en
Meuse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Je note avec satisfaction
qu'une députée qui se
qualifiait de "parachutée"
s'intéresse aux entreprises de son
territoire.
Nous n'avons pas attendu votre
parachutage.
C'est comme cela que vous vous
qualifiez pour vous occuper de
l'industrie française.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: On écoute la
réponse du ministre!
- Roland Lescure: Depuis plus de
cinq ans, ce gouvernement s'est
attelé à la réindustrialisation de
la France.
Brouhaha
Même si cela vous déplaît!
Vous vous nourrissez de la
désindustrialisation depuis 25
ans.
Nous avons créé des milliers
d'emplois et nous avons ouvert
plus d'usines que nous n'en avons
fermé l'année dernière.
Cela dit, malheureusement, des
usines ferment en France.
Ca arrive, et cela arrive dans
votre circonscription.
Comme toutes les usines qui
ferment, nous sommes aux côtés des
salariés et des territoires,
quelle que soit la couleur des
députés en question.
Pour cette entreprise et cette
usine, comme pour toutes les
autres, nous rencontrons la
direction.
Mon équipe l'a fait hier.
Nous rencontrons les organisations
syndicales.
N'en déplaise à celles et ceux qui
pensent que nous n'aimons pas le
dialogue social.
Nous accompagnons les salariés.
Nous accompagnons l'entreprise
pour trouver un repreneur.
Nous serons prêts, comme
d'habitude, à accompagner le
repreneur dans cette opération.
Nous croyons en l'industrie
française.
Vous vous nourrissez de son
déclin.
Nous sommes d'accord pour ne pas
être d'accord.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-François Coulomme.
- Jean-François Coulomme: Conseil
de l'Europe, Ligue des droits de
l'homme, Amnesty International, le
Parlement belge, tous les
observateurs de ce cauchemar que
vous avez provoqué dénoncent le
sinistre théâtre que vous mettez
en scène.
Une police qui roule à moto sur un
manifestant à terre, qui matraque
et qui gaze à bout portant, la
police qui tire sur une mère de
famille, qui tire sur un
syndicaliste, qui agresse
sexuellement les manifestantes,
qui agresse les jeunes, et encore
plus...
L'agresseur n'est pas l'arme, mais
celui qui l'actionne.
Vous êtes allés trop loin
avec notre police.
Nos policiers ne sont pas engagés
pour être vos instruments du
matraquage de tout un peuple qui
conteste votre coup de force.
La justice, sur injonction de son
ministre, est sommée d'infliger
une réponse pénale rapide, se
mettant au service
d'interpellations arbitraires dont
les victimes ressortent
majoritairement exemptes de motifs
de poursuite.
Pénaliser notre liberté de faire
grève et de manifester, mais
légaliser les cassages de piquets
de grève?
Répression policière et répression
judiciaire sont les deux problèmes
de cette macronie de réforme.
Quand allez-vous cesser d'infliger
votre sanglante recette du bonheur
à tout un peuple qui n'en veut
pas?
Quand allez-vous cesser de faire
confronter policiers et
manifestants en les mettant tous
les deux en danger mortel?
Quand allez-vous cesser de dévoyer
notre pays en mettant ces gardiens
de la paix, ces juristes et ces
institutions, à votre propre
profit?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, il y a de cela
quelques mois, voire quelques
années, c'était après le Bataclan,
on voulait embrasser les flics.
Aujourd'hui, vous vomissez dessus.
Voilà la réalité.
Je veux ici rappeler que monsieur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, votre leader,
a été condamné définitivement pour
avoir exercé des violences sur des
policiers et sur un procureur de
la République.
Voilà, monsieur le député, la
réalité.
Je vais maintenant vous dire que,
par les temps troublés que nous
traversons, je vous suggère
d'avoir à portée de main le code
pénal.
Nous ne nous sommes affranchis
d'aucune règle démocratique.
Dans le code de procédure pénale,
vous pourrez lire que les gardes à
vue, que vous fustigez, sont en
réalité une mesure coercitive
prise par un officier de police
judiciaire sous le contrôle d'un
procureur à chaque fois qu'il y a
une raison plausible de suspecter
qu'une infraction a été commise.
Ce n'est pas plus compliqué que
cela, monsieur le député.
Ensuite, la justice vient faire
son travail.
La garde à vue, c'est une raison
plausible.
La mise en examen, c'est grave et
concordant.
La condamnation, ce sont des
preuves.
Si vous n'êtes pas convaincu, je
vous suggère ce week-end une
balade à la campagne, sans
essence, sans cagoule, et sans
cocktail Molotov.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Monsieur le député?
- Jean-François Coulomme:
Retirez votre loi scélérate.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: la parole est
à monsieur Nicolas Turquois.
- Nicolas Turquois: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
des Outre-mer.
Je tiens à exprimer notre soutien
total aux habitants de
Sainte-Soline et à leurs proches.
Depuis des semaines, ils vivent un
quotidien des faits de harcèlement
et d'intimidation.
Ils redoutent que leurs familles
soient victimes d'actions de
sabotage.
Ce week-end, ils ont vécu l'enfer.
Je veux rendre un hommage appuyé
aux gendarmes et aux pompiers qui
ont servi au péril de leur vie.
Cette manifestation jugée
dangereuse et violente était
interdite.
Elle a dépassé tous les
qualificatifs et son bilan était
dramatique.
Nous condamnons avec force
l'attitude d'élus de la République
qui ont participé à cette
événement interdit ou qui ont
parlé de déambulation joyeuse et
festive, alors que des centaines
de personnes masquées et armées
ont foncé et ont attaqué les
forces de l'ordre à coups de
pierres, ou de cocktails Molotov.
Le combat des idées est légitime,
il peut être rude, mais aucune
violence n'est acceptable en
démocratie.
Il nous faut enfin dénoncer ces
groupuscules d'extrême gauche,
qui, sous des noms poétiques,
organisent et planifient ces
déchaînements de violence sous
couvert d'une cause écologique,
qui n'a pour objectif que mettre
la France à feu et à sang.
La République ne peut tolérer de
tels déferlements de violence.
Face à l'ampleur de ce qu'il s'est
passé ce week-end, que
comptez-vous faire pour qu'aucun
agriculteur ni sa famille ne
revive un jour comme celui-ci?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Comme l'a fait le ministre de
l'Agriculture, comme l'a fait
également Christophe Béchu, je
veux dire tout notre soutien aux
agriculteurs français, à leurs
outils de travail, à leurs biens
et à leurs familles, évidemment.
Savez-vous, monsieur le député,
que lors des événements
dramatiques de Sainte-Soline,
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été
menacés et ont dû quitter leur
ferme.
Ils ont laissé leur bétail et
leurs outils de production
derrière eux pour éviter,
justement, de connaître des
menaces physiques.
Combien ont-ils reçu de menaces?
La protection policière et des
gendarmes est complète, notamment
dans cette partie de l'ouest de la
France, pour les protéger contre
toutes les menaces.
Aucune ZAD ne s'est installée à
Sainte-Soline, ni il y a six mois,
ni le week-end dernier.
Oui, Sainte-Soline, ce sont des
méga-bassines qui ont été
discutées avec des professionnels,
validées avec les élus, et je
voudrais aussi souligner qu'elles
ont été validées par la justice.
Nous ne nous laisserons pas faire
par des militants d'ultra gauche
menaçants et qui s'en prennent
directement aux agriculteurs.
Derrière les bassines, il ne
s'agit pas seulement d'endroits où
il y a de l'eau, mais il s'agit de
la vie de milliers de personnes
qui se lèvent tôt, qui se couchent
tard, et qui sont menacés chaque
jour par des personnes radicales.
Ils nourrissent les Français et
ils méritent notre respect plutôt
que des insultes!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sophie
Taillé-Polian.
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Merci.
Excusez-moi.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au premier
flic de France.
Hier, lors de votre conférence de
presse, vous avez longuement
détaillé le déploiement d'un
gigantesque dispositif d'agents de
police et de gendarmerie.
A chaque mobilisation, c'est
l'escalade.
Pensez-vous réellement pouvoir
demander aux forces de l'ordre de
résoudre la crise politique
majeure qui traverse notre pays?
Quasiment une crise de régime, par
la faute du gouvernement auquel
vous appartenez, par la faute du
président, qui de plus en plus
isolé dans son château,
s'obstine à faire passer une
réforme par la force.
Par vos décisions, vous mettez en
danger les citoyens qui
manifestent, mais aussi les forces
de l'ordre, de manière totalement
injustifiée.
A ce jour, pas moins de 17
enquêtes ont été ouvertes à
l'IGPN.
Sans parler des coups de matraque
et vos voltigeurs.
Des jeunes femmes ont été victimes
d'agressions sexuelles à Nantes.
Il y a des milliers de victimes de
grenades de désencerclement.
Ces violences sont aujourd'hui
documentées, filmées, visibles.
On ne peut pas continuer de les
ignorer.
Il semble que vous cherchez à
attiser les tensions afin
d'incarner l'ordre et de sortir de
cette crise par le retour à
l'autorité.
Vous instrumentalisez les agents
de police.
Il faut en sortir par la raison.
Quand allez-vous arrêter d'être le
premier flic de France pour
devenir ministre de l'Intérieur,
c'est-à-dire au service de
l'intérêt général et de la
démocratie?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Permettez-moi tout d'abord de vous
dire que je ne suis pas le premier
flic de France.
Je n'ai pas le courage, ni vous,
d'ailleurs, d'être à la place des
personnes qui risquent chaque jour
leur vie pour défendre nos
concitoyens.
Vous me demandez, madame la
députée, ce qu'il s'est passé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame!
Brouhaha
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous me
demandez ce qu'il s'est passé.
Que s'est-il passé à gauche pour
que l'on confonde casseurs et
policiers?
Que s'est-il passé à gauche pour
que l'on n'ait pas un mot pour
tous ces policiers et ces
gendarmes qui sont blessés?
Que s'est-il passé à gauche quand
on n'a pas un mot, lorsque l'on
attaque des commissariats, des
préfectures ou des permanences de
parlementaires?
Que s'est-il passé à gauche pour
que l'on confonde manifestation
interdite et manifestation
autorisée?
Que s'est-il passé à gauche pour
que l'on ne respecte plus
l'uniforme de la République?
Que s'est-il passé à gauche pour
que l'on oublie à ce point
Clémenceau et Mitterrand?
Que s'est-il passé à gauche pour
faire alliance avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon, qui les insulte, qui
les vomit, et qui fait honte à
tous les électeurs de gauche?
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Je n'ai
insulté personne, mais vous n'avez
pas répondu à ma question!
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous devriez
présenter vos excuses aux
policiers et aux gendarmes que
vous blessez chaque jour!
Vous devriez présenter vos excuses
à l'uniforme de la République sur
lequel vous crachez!
Vous devriez présenter vos
excuses!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Christine
Pires Beaune.
- Christine Pires Beaune: Madame
la Première ministre, vous n'avez
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale, d'où le 49.3.
Vous n'avez pas de perspective
politique, d'où votre appel aux
syndicats à parler de tout, sauf
des retraites.
Avez-vous conscience de ce qu'il
se passe dans le pays?
On peut en douter quand on entend
vos propos hallucinants sur votre
prétendue victoire.
Vous parlez d'une volonté de
désordre dans les cortèges de
manifestants, mais il n'y a rien
de plus faux.
Ils parlent de démocratie, du
respect du travail et des
travailleurs.
Ces caricatures vous éloignent
chaque jour un peu plus du peuple.
Madame la Première ministre, notre
pays a besoin d'apaisement.
Vous voulez un nouveau départ,
mais il n'y en aura pas, ni avec
les groupes parlementaires, ni
avec les partenaires sociaux, tant
que la loi retraite n'aura pas été
remisée.
C'est la méthode Coué.
Vous ne changerez pas de séquence
à votre gré.
Le peuple va dicter l'ordre du
jour et celui-ci appelle des
mesures en faveur de l'hôpital
public, en faveur des EHPAD, en
faveur des Français confrontés à
l'inflation, en faveur des
territoires oubliés.
Vous voulez gouverner?
Ecoutez l'Assemblée nationale.
Ecoutez le peuple.
Ecoutez la démocratie, le respect
du pouvoir législatif, pas son
enjambement.
La démocratie, c'est l'écoute de
la volonté du peuple.
Le peuple, ce n'est pas la foule,
même s'il y a effectivement foule
dans la rue.
Vous voulez sortir de votre
isolement?
Vous voulez trouver des majorités
à l'Assemblée?
Ce ne sera pas simple, mais il y a
un préalable attendu par beaucoup,
y compris par certains dans votre
majorité: le retrait de la réforme
des retraites.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est un monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Vous nous appelez à respecter la
volonté du peuple et du Parlement.
Le premier respect, c'est de
respecter les urnes.
Le président a fait campagne avec
un engagement: réformer le système
des retraites.
Cette réforme a été conduite dans
la concertation.
Elle a été conduite avec 175
heures de débats au Parlement.
Des modifications ont été
apportées pour les carrières
longues et pour la pénibilité.
Des mesures ont été apportées
grâce au travail de la majorité
présidentielle.
Vous nous dites qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité.
Je vous rejoins sur un point, il
n'y a pas de majorité, et les
débats l'ont signifié.
Mais vous n'avez pas permis
d'empêcher l'adoption du texte.
Vous êtes en échec parce que votre
stratégie est liée à celle de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Vous appartenez à un parti
tellement affilié à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon, que vous ne pensez
plus, que vous ne décidez plus.
Vous n'avez plus de souveraineté
ni de capacité à penser à votre
propre avenir.
Je me souviens d'une interview de
Bernard Cazeneuve qui avait dit
que le Parti Socialiste était
devenu le paillasson de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon.
Il avait raison.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Thierry Benoit.
- Thierry Benoit: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, il y
a un sujet de réflexion qui
persiste dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens, c'est le partage des
richesses créées et le reste à
vivre pour les travailleurs,
qu'ils soient salariés du secteur
public ou privé, qu'ils soient
artisans ou éleveurs, travaillant
dans le secteur de la santé ou du
médico-social.
Lorsque les besoins vitaux sont
mis à mal, se nourrir, se loger,
se déplacer, il est nécessaire de
s'interroger sur les mesures qui
sont rapidement mises en oeuvre
pour revaloriser les bas salaires
et travailler à un meilleur
partage de la richesse créée.
Ces dernières années, des secteurs
faisant de superprofits se sont
révélés, notamment au cours des
crises successives qui frappent la
vie de nos concitoyens et de notre
économie.
Le e-commerce, les banques, les
assurances, les entreprises
énergétiques, les compagnies
maritimes, les GAFAM...
Il y a une nécessité de
revaloriser dès maintenant les bas
salaires.
Dans le même temps, il faut taxer
certains profits exorbitants et
disproportionnés.
Ainsi, il faut mettre à
contribution les secteurs qui font
des profits très élevés.
Le gouvernement est-il prêt à
bâtir avec les partenaires sociaux
un plan d'action, une conférence
sociale sur le reste à vivre et
sur le meilleur partage des
richesses créées?
Le gouvernement est-il prêt à se
coordonner avec les autres
gouvernements de l'Union
Européenne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je commencerai
par la fin de votre question.
Le reste à vivre, que vous avez
mentionné, je me souviens des
avancées auxquelles vous avez
contribué dès 2019 avec le groupe
MoDem.
Nous sommes absolument disposés,
plus que jamais, à avancer sur une
valeur mieux distribuée pour les
salariés.
Vous avez aussi mentionné la
situation de nos compatriotes en
matière d'inflation.
Vous avez dit: "se nourrir, se
loger, se déplacer..."
Ce n'est pas un hasard.
Ce sont les secteurs les plus
lourds dans les dépenses des
mineurs.
Paul Eluard disait qu'il n'y avait
pas de hasards.
Il n'y a que des rendez-vous.
Le gouvernement a été au
rendez-vous sur chacun de ces
postes.
La remise carburant, nous sommes
là.
L'aide à l'énergie, nous sommes
Je rappelle le bouclier jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 2023 pour que nos
compatriotes n'aient pas à subir
l'inflation sur leurs factures
d'énergie.
Je pense aussi aux plus fragiles.
Il y a aussi la revalorisation des
bourses étudiantes, des APL...
Nous avons déployé depuis un an
plus de 4 milliards d'euros, une
prime de partage de la valeur pour
plusieurs milliers de salariés.
Les entrepreneurs ont partagé la
valeur.
Faut-il faire plus?
Faut-il faire mieux?
On peut se poser la question.
Mais vous pouvez être rassuré.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jérôme Legavre.
- Jérôme Legavre: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Ville et du Logement.
Il est beaucoup question de
violence ces derniers jours, et le
gouvernement est prompt à en faire
porter la responsabilité à
quiconque refuse de baisser les
yeux.
La moitié du pays vit avec moins
de 1900 euros par mois.
Vous avez diminué le montant des
APL.
Nombreux étudiants sont obligés de
louer à prix d'or leur
appartement.
Et cela, c'est votre politique.
Le manque de logements sociaux est
criant.
Le préfet de Seine-Saint-Denis
indique que dans son département,
118.000 demandes de logement ne
peuvent être satisfaites.
Les 10% les plus modestes
consacrent plus de 40% de leur
revenu au logement.
Le nombre d'impayés depuis trois
mois a augmenté de 10% en un an
dans le parc social.
Les expulsions locatives
reprennent de plus belle.
Il y a deux fois plus de
sans-domicile-fixe en 2012.
A cela s'ajoute l'explosion de
tous les prix: électricité, gaz...
Les habitants des logements
collectifs sont exclus des
boucliers tarifaires des
particuliers et toutes les charges
explosent.
C'est pourquoi je souhaite vous
interroger.
Allez-vous décider la diminution
des loyers en imposant un taux
négatif?
Allez-vous augmenter les APL?
Allez-vous décider le blocage réel
des tarifs de l'énergie et le
retour au tarif réglementé?
Il y a plusieurs copropriétés de
ma circonscription menacées de
faillite.
Les bailleurs envoient des
courriers terrifiants à leurs
locataires.
Les habitants savent qu'ils ne
pourront pas payer.
Vous avez le pouvoir et la
responsabilité de désamorcer cette
bombe sociale.
Je vous remercie d'indiquer si
vous envisagez de prendre des
mesures d'urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, oui, la
situation du logement dans notre
pays est une situation complexe.
Oui, le poste de dépenses liées au
logement est un des premiers
postes de dépenses de nos
concitoyens.
Mais oui, le gouvernement agit
avec les parlementaires de la
majorité, d'abord dans le cadre de
la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat.
Nous avons augmenté les APL de
3,5%.
Nous avons décidé de plafonner
l'augmentation du loyer pour que
les bailleurs sociaux puissent
continuer les nécessaires
opérations de rénovation
thermique.
Oui, nous avons agi sur un
bouclier tarifaire individuel, sur
le gaz et l'électricité.
Oui, nous avons complété le
bouclier tarifaire collectif, et
vous le savez, sur le gaz et
l'électricité, y compris sur les
parties communes, et vous le
savez, y compris sur les
copropriétés de ma
circonscription.
Nous les suivons ensemble.
Oui, nous agissons pour qu'il y
ait plus de logements dans ce
pays.
C'est le sens du
Plan logement.
Oui, nous agissons pour les plus
fragiles en lançant le plan
logement et l'hébergement
d'urgence à l'Etat où il était
alors que nous l'avons trouvé, à
moins de 120.000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Vous avez deux secondes.
- Jérôme Lagrave: Recevez-moi,
monsieur le ministre.
- Olivier Klein: Il va rester du
temps, madame.
Monsieur le député, je reçois
quand vous voulez.
Nous en avons déjà parlé.
Surtout, je vois les copropriétés
en question.
J'ai eu la présidente...
Oui, nous continuons à agir sur
l'ensemble des copropriétés de ce
pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
On remet le chronomètre à zéro,
s'il vous plaît.
Olivier Marleix, pour les
Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix: Madame la
Première ministre, le président de
la République semble avoir
découvert le mot de souveraineté
depuis sa réélection.
En parler, c'est bien.
Pratiquer, c'est mieux.
Deux événements m'amènent à vous
interroger sur votre
détermination.
Le premier, c'est le projet de
rachat d'une entreprise française
fabricante de robinetterie de
haute performance qui équipe nos
sous-marins nucléaires par une
autre américaine.
La conséquence de ce passage, ce
serait que l'exportation et la
vente de nos sous-marins, qui
n'est pas toujours brillante,
serait soumise désormais à
l'autorisation du gouvernement des
Etats-Unis du fait de la
législation.
Pouvez-vous nous dire clairement
que vous allez vous opposer à ce
projet, que vous ferez valoir
votre veto?
Le second événement, c'est ce
Conseil européen du 23 mars
dernier, au cours duquel la
présidente de la commission a
présenté le projet industrie.
Ce projet exclut la plupart des
investissements dans la filière
nucléaire pour des raisons
purement idéologiques et
absolument irrationnelles.
Je vous le demande solennellement.
Jusqu'à quel point votre
gouvernement est déterminé à se
battre pour obtenir l'inscription
de l'ensemble des investissements
dans le nucléaire dans ce projet
de règlement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président Olivier
Marleix, je pense que nous pouvons
nous accorder sur une chose: la
nécessité de réindustrialiser
notre pays.
Le retour de notre industrie,
c'est à la fois un enjeu de
souveraineté, d'emploi, de
création de richesse, et c'est
enfin un enjeu sur l'équilibre du
développement de notre territoire.
Monsieur le président, depuis six
ans, les résultats sont là.
Nous avons inversé la tendance de
décennies de désindustrialisation.
La France a retrouvé son
attractivité en devenant la
première destination des
investissements directs,
étrangers, en Europe.
Entre 2017 et 2022, ce sont près
de 60.000 emplois qui ont été
créés dans l'industrie.
Monsieur le président Olivier
Marleix, si l'industrie a fait son
retour en France, c'est grâce aux
réformes et aux investissements
engagés depuis 2017.
Je pense aux réformes du marché du
travail.
Je pense à la baisse de 10
milliards d'euros des impôts de
production, je pense au soutien du
gouvernement à nos entreprises, au
travers de France relance, et
désormais de France 2030.
Avec France relance, ce sont plus
de 12 milliards d'euros qui ont
été investis, et 2800 projets qui
sont soutenus.
Ces investissements, ce sont des
emplois, des chaînes de
production, des compétences, de
l'attractivité pour tous nos
territoires.
Vous m'interrogez sur le cas de
cette entreprise.
Un éventuel projet de rachat n'en
est qu'à ses débuts.
Nous serons très vigilants et en
tout état de cause, cette
opération est soumise au contrôle
des investissements étrangers en
France.
Quant à la proposition de la
commission que vous mentionnez,
nous sommes déterminés, dans le
cadre des négociations au sein du
conseil, avec les 10 autres
Etats-membres que nous avons
réunis dans l'alliance du
nucléaire en Europe,
à convaincre que le nucléaire est
une filière stratégique pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone.
Monsieur le président Olivier
Marleix, comme l'a dit le
président de la République, la
réindustrialisation est au coeur
des chantiers devant nous, au
coeur des consultations que
j'engage pour bâtir un programme
de gouvernement et un agenda
législatif avec tous ceux qui
veulent trouver des solutions pour
notre pays.
Sur la réindustrialisation, c'est
un sujet, comme sur d'autres, sur
lequel je vous propose de
travailler, d'échanger, de
construire dans les prochaines
semaines.
Nous le ferons avec les forces
politiques, avec les
parlementaires, avec les élus
locaux, et je l'espère avec les
partenaires sociaux, à qui nous
tendons la main.
C'est de cette manière, par le
dialogue avec toutes les bonnes
volontés, que nous répondons aux
inquiétudes, que nous apaiserons
notre société et que nous
accélérerons pour répondre aux
préoccupations des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
Monsieur le président Olivier
Marleix?
- Olivier Marleix: Je regrette de
ne pas avoir entendu le mot
"souveraineté" dans votre réponse.
C'était essentiel dans ma
question.
Je voudrais vous rappeler que la
semaine dernière, nous avons voté,
avec une large majorité, à 68%, un
texte de relance du nucléaire.
Je crois que c'est un mandat très
clair qui vous a été donné.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Barthès pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Christophe Barthès: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
10.000, ce seront 10.000 personnes
qui se retrouveront sans médecin
traitant le 1er juillet à
Carcassonne.
Carcassonne et ses environs sont
un immense désert médical.
Voilà plus de 10 ans que les
médecins que j'ai reçus dans ma
permanence vous alertent et
alertent les élus locaux.
Selon vous, tout va pour le mieux.
Le sondage réalisé est faussé.
Beaucoup de médecins sont
installés avec l'étiquette médecin
généraliste et ont une activité
spécifique et ne possèdent aucun
patient en tant que médecin
traitant.
Quelques aides ont été mises en
place concernant les étudiants,
mais rien de plus.
A Carcassonne, cette situation va
empirer avec une très grande
rapidité.
Derrière votre numéro
d'autosatisfaction, c'est une
conjoncture catastrophique qui va
se dégrader et prendre en otage la
santé des habitants de
Carcassonne.
Dans de nombreux territoires
ruraux, il devient très difficile
de trouver un médecin et d'avoir
rendez-vous dans de très brefs
délais.
A cause de votre politique, ils
n'auront bientôt plus de médecin
traitant et n'auront comme contact
local qu'une infirmière ou un
infirmier.
Quelles solutions avez-vous pour
la ville de Carcassonne et ses
10.000 habitants, qui vont se
retrouver sans médecin traitant à
partir du 1er juillet?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun, ministre de la Santé, de la
prévention.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Barthès, je
vous remercie de partager ce
diagnostic qui est largement
répandu sur les difficultés de nos
systèmes de santé,
particulièrement dans votre
secteur que je connais bien.
Il y a aussi Castelnaudary.
Il y a des difficultés d'accès à
la santé.
Les solutions sont aussi dans les
territoires.
Avec 150 réunions que nous avons
conduites, avec les préfectures,
nous adaptons des solutions à
chaque territoire.
Ces solutions sont multiples.
On pourra avoir l'occasion de
toutes les détailler, que ce soit
de l'exercice coordonné, que ce
soient les cabinets de groupe...
En ce qui concerne les réponses
aux solutions qu'il y a, elles
sont aussi territoriales dans
votre secteur, qui est innovant en
ce qui concerne le monde de
l'hôpital.
Il y a des aides qui sont faites
par les hôpitaux autour, en
particulier par le CHU de
Toulouse, qui intervient aussi sur
Castelnaudary pour aider à la
prise en charge des soins urgents.
En ce qui concerne les personnes
sans médecin traitant, j'ai lancé
la semaine dernière la campagne
pour que les patients qui n'ont
plus de médecin traitant en
maladies chroniques, la caisse
primaire d'assurance-maladie les
contacte un par un pour trouver
des solutions.
Il faut aussi aider au maintien
des praticiens les plus âgés.
C'est tout ce qui est fait dans le
cadre du cumul possible
emploi-retraite.
Concernant les territoires, je
vous rappelle que les réunions
sont organisées.
En tant que parlementaires, vous y
êtes invité à chaque fois, mais je
suis désolé de vous dire qu'on ne
vous y a pas encore vu.
- Christophe Barthès: Vous ne
m'avez pas vu parce que j'étais
ici dans l'hémicycle.
Je ne peux pas être partout à la
fois.
Vous ne m'avez pas répondu pour
les 10.000 personnes à
Carcassonne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Servane
Hugues pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Servane Hugues: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre en charge des Personnes
handicapées.
Le 2 avril prochain, il y aura la
Journée mondiale de
sensibilisation à l'autisme.
Tous les Français sont invités à
porter du bleu pour exprimer leur
soutien au mouvement.
En France, 700.000 personnes
vivent avec un trouble du spectre
de l'autisme.
Elles doivent affronter
l'incompréhension de la société
quant à leur handicap invisible,
marqué par une représentation
souvent très caricaturale.
La stratégie nationale pour la
période 2018 à 2022 pour l'autisme
et le trouble du redéveloppement
sur tout le parcours de vie des
personnes touchées par l'autisme.
Cette stratégie a permis de
travailler avec différents
ministères, Santé, Education
nationale, Enseignement supérieur,
Travail, Logement.
J'en suis persuadée, le handicap
doit s'inscrire dans une politique
globale, transversale, dans une
logique de construction avec tous
les ministères.
Ce travail est aujourd'hui
largement amorcé.
Néanmoins, et malgré ces grandes
avancées, encore trop de familles
concernées restent isolées, sans
accompagnement adapté ni solutions
de répit.
Quel bilan tirez-vous de la
stratégie 2018 à 2022, et quelle
suite est envisagée aujourd'hui?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Madame
la députée, je veux vous remercier
d'attirer notre attention à tous
sur l'autisme et les troubles de
néodéveloppement et d'avoir parlé
de cette journée du 2 avril, qui
est la Journée mondiale de
l'autisme.
Alors oui, depuis 2018, la
stratégie nationale a déployé 550
millions d'euros qui ont été mis
en oeuvre dans le cadre de cette
régie.
Structurer la recherche, d'abord,
vous l'avez dit.
Cinq centres d'excellence ont été
formés, structurés.
Un groupement d'intérêt
scientifique.
Ce qui fait que la recherche
nationale est à l'avant-garde de
la recherche européenne
aujourd'hui.
Je crois que ça peut être une
fierté pour nous.
Deuxièmement, repérer précocement
les enfants, prendre en charge
précocement au sein de ces
plates-formes de coordination.
97 places ont été créées.
41.000 enfants ont été pris en
charge au sein de ces
plates-formes.
C'est assez important pour être
souligné.
Bien entendu, les dispositifs
médico-sociaux inclus dans
l'école, que ce soit l'école
maternelle, école primaire, les
collèges, 440 dispositifs
médico-sociaux afin d'aider les
enfants à intégrer l'école de la
République.
Et bien sûr, on pourra
accompagner.
Ces personnes accèdent à l'emploi
également, et on les accompagne à
pouvoir rentrer dans les
entreprises et à accéder à des
emplois de qualité.
Et puis nous avons bien sûr mis en
oeuvre des lieux pour les autistes
avec des troubles très complexes,
des lieux de résidence, afin de
les protéger et de faire en sorte
de les prendre en charge de façon
efficace.
Tout se construit avec
associations et des personnes
handicapées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Estelle Youssouffa.
- Estelle Youssouffa: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique et de
la Cohésion des territoires.
Elle est au sujet de son plan de
l'eau.
Nous vous entendons évoquer le
risque de la sécheresse et de
coupures dans l'Hexagone, je vous
rappelle que Mayotte connaît tous
les jours des coupures d'eau
pendant plus de 12 heures depuis
plusieurs années.
La situation est gravissime et
empire.
Quand il n'y a pas d'eau de pluie,
le système de dessalement est
insuffisant pour alimenter l'île.
Quand il pleut trop, le système de
filtrage est saturé et produit une
eau imbuvable.
Hier, c'était de l'eau bleue.
Ailleurs, il n'y avait pas d'eau
du tout alors que la population
est en plein mois de ramadan.
Impossible de cuisiner ni de
respecter des règles d'hygiène
minimum dans les foyers.
Totalement à sec, les
établissements scolaires ont fermé
et renvoyé les élèves.
Mayotte paye des factures d'eau
faramineuse pour des robinets
désespérément vides.
Le préfet se refuse à plafonner le
prix des packs d'eau, qui peut
atteindre jusqu'à 10 voire 12
euros pour six bouteilles.
Vous allez me dire que 416
millions d'euros sont mis sur la
table avec le contrat de progrès
entre l'Etat et les eaux de
Mayotte.
Mais rien n'est opérationnel.
La campagne de prospection de
forage n'a pas commencé.
Aucun travaux n'a commencé.
Nous ne pouvons plus entendre dans
la bouche de l'Etat: "Ce n'est pas
moi, c'est une compétence des
collectivités locales."
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-François Carenco.
- Jean-François Carenco: Votre
question vient à point pour me
permettre d'exposer les travaux
déjà engagés et les mesures déjà
prises.
Sur les difficultés structurelles,
je vous prie de croire que nous y
travaillons.
Les projets sont repartis depuis
six mois.
Ils avaient été bloqués.
Les procédures concernant la
création de la troisième retenue
colinéaire et de la deuxième usine
de dessalement afin d'augmenter
les capacités de production de
5000 m3 sont aujourd'hui
débloqués.
J'attends les arrêtés d'utilité
publique.
S'agissant de l'usine de
dessalement actuel, des travaux
sont en cours afin d'augmenter la
capacité de production.
Vous savez que c'est le
gouvernement qui a débloqué la
situation.
Les crédits sont disponibles.
Les procédures ont été longues.
J'allais dire que l'administration
partagée à Mayotte est en cet
égard un peu long aussi.
J'avais demandé au préfet
d'accélérer davantage, et c'est ce
qui est fait.
Sur la sécheresse actuelle, nous
devons réagir et nous y
travaillons depuis environ 15
jours, depuis que l'on sait
qu'elle arrive.
Je l'ai évoqué ce matin même avec
la Première ministre et le
président.
J'ai demandé aux deux grands
distributeurs présents à Mayotte
de vendre de l'eau à prix coûtant,
sans aucune marge, pendant les six
prochains mois.
Un des deux a d'ores et déjà donné
son accord et j'attends l'accord
du deuxième.
Je vous annonce que d'ici 15
jours, grâce à la mobilisation de
la sécurité civile et sur
l'instruction du ministre de
l'Intérieur, 400 m3 par jour
seront disponibles gratuitement
pour les plus démunis.
L'objectif est d'atteindre 900 m3
par jour pour les plus démunis.
Je reviendrai vers vous
prochainement pour préciser les
choses s'agissant des procédures
de distribution.
Les mesures sont prises et vous
savez pourquoi ils ont traîné.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Taite pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Jean-Pierre Taite: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
Monsieur, je vous parle au nom des
Français qui veulent être soignés
proches de chez eux.
La loi prendra effet le 3 avril
avec des conséquences
catastrophiques pour nos hôpitaux
publics.
Les urgences fonctionnent avec des
médecins intérimaires au côté des
titulaires, dans la Loire.
Avec cette loi, les médecins
intérimaires désertent et les
urgences sont menacées de
fermeture.
La revalorisation de 20% de votre
ministère annonce arriver alors
que les services sont au bord du
gouffre.
Monsieur le ministre, si vous ne
suspendez pas immédiatement
l'application de cette loi, vous
serez le fossoyeur de l'hôpital
public.
Et nos concitoyens seront en
situation de non-assistance à
personne en danger.
Nous avons un conseil de
surveillance exceptionnelle lundi
3 avril en sous-préfecture de
Montbrison.
Ma question est simple et sans
détour.
Quel message vous portez?
Au nom des élus du territoire, des
personnels et des concitoyens, je
vous invite à visiter notre
hôpital.
Vous constaterez que sur le
terrain, les difficultés sont
réelles et que nos personnels sont
en souffrance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à François Braun,
ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Jean-Pierre
Taite, vous avez raison, si nous
n'agissons pas, c'est là que notre
hôpital public est menacé.
Ces intérimaires mercenaires, je
ne parle pas des intérimaires qui
font leur travail normalement,
mais ces intérimaires mercenaires,
qui jusqu'à la veille au soir,
annoncent qu'ils ne viendront pas
si on n'augmente pas les prix pour
la nuit, ce sont eux qui sont en
train de détruire notre hôpital
public.
N'ayons aucun doute là-dessus.
Ils s'attaquent préférentiellement
aux petits hôpitaux, si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi, qui sont les
plus fragiles, loin des grandes
villes et qui ont du mal à
maintenir leur ligne de garde.
L'objectif est clair: il faut un
signe fort par rapport à ces
intérimaires mercenaires, tout en
valorisant l'exercice des médecins
qui tiennent la ligne dans nos
hôpitaux.
C'est ce que je suis en train de
faire.
Il faut valoriser leurs conditions
d'exercice, leur pénibilité,
continuer sur la ligne que j'ai
mise en place cet été pour
maintenir les permanences de
soins.
La proximité, vous l'avez dit,
c'est un objectif majeur des
soins.
Je lutte contre cette inégalité
territoriale d'accès aux soins par
plusieurs mesures.
Il y a également la qualité qui
doit être au rendez-vous.
Nous devons avoir tous ensemble
des solutions.
Nous devons toujours avoir en tête
ce binôme: qualité et sécurité.
L'intérim doit s'arrêter dans ces
dispositions inacceptables.
Il doit perdurer dans des
conditions qui sont normales.
Nous considérons que 1390 euros
brut, sans compter les frais de
déplacement, de logement et de
nourriture, c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait acceptable pour un
médecin intérimaire qui vient
travailler.
Je ne doute pas que la grande
majorité des médecins intérimaires
qui travaillent dans de bonnes
conditions et qui travaillent en
respectant ce règlement en
respectant ce plafond continueront
à venir dans nos hôpitaux.
Pour les autres, une analyse
précise est faite encore cette
semaine, jour après jour, sur
toutes les situations, pour
proposer des solutions dans le
cadre d'entraide territoriale ou
des solutions alternatives.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Allez-y, mon
cher collègue.
- Jean-Pierre Taite: J'écouterai
avec respect votre réponse.
Je pense que je vais réitérer mon
invitation.
Je pense que sur tous ces bancs,
notre objectif commun est de
défendre l'objectif public.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Claude Raux pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Jean-Claude Raux: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, la
jeunesse que vous souhaitez est
muselée.
Celle que nous connaissons est
engagée.
Elle est engagée pour être
entendue parce que disons-le, le
gouvernement a peur de la
jeunesse.
Il refuse donc avec obstination de
l'écouter et préfère la mettre au
pas.
Si peur, que je n'ose imaginer
votre réaction après le tournant
de jeudi dernier.
Ce 23 mars, la jeunesse est
descendue en masse manifester aux
80 universités qui ont été
bloquées, et les lycées se sont
aussi mobilisés.
Combien seront-ils aujourd'hui?
L'avenir que vous lui réservez,
c'est la précarité, quand ce
qu'elle souhaite, c'est être
émancipée, avoir des droits et un
accès égal à la citoyenneté dès 18
ans.
Depuis six ans, nous assistons à
une accumulation de politique
publique à l'encontre des jeunes.
Au terme de ces six années, la
jeunesse est en feu plutôt que
d'être en fleur.
Elle a un avenir à plus quatre
degrés, logique qu'elle se
réchauffe.
Mais ne vous y trompez pas.
Elle se lève quand on lui répond
par le mépris et la force.
Elle se lève, on l'étouffe, on la
laisse se consumer.
Elle se lève pour ériger une
société où l'on peut vivre et
vieillir autrement.
Madame la Première ministre, ils
retiennent le slogan: "Sois jeune
et tais-toi."
Que leur répondez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sarah El
Haïry.
- Sarah El Haïry: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur le député.
Vous parlez de la jeunesse, nous
l'accompagnons.
Depuis 2017, nous ne parlons pas
de la jeunesse au singulier.
On l'accompagne au pluriel.
Ca commence dès le plus jeune âge,
quand on permet à l'école le
dédoublement des classes de CP et
de CE1, quand on met en place des
petits déjeuners gratuits.
On n'étudie pas de la même manière
quand on a le ventre plein ou
vide.
On lui permet d'ouvrir le champ
des possibles quand on permet à
plus de 225.000 jeunes de partir
en vacances.
Quand on va chercher plus de
300.000 jeunes avec un contrat
d'engagement jeune, c'est 300.000
décrocheurs en moins.
Quand l'apprentissage dépasse tous
les records, c'est l'accès à
l'emploi.
Quand on passe à moins de 16% de
taux de chômage des jeunes, c'est
le chemin de l'émancipation.
Quand la jeunesse est à la table
de Matignon chaque samedi, c'est
elle que nous écoutons.
Vous parlez de la jeunesse, nous,
on l'accompagne.
Vous l'instrumentalisez, combattez
avec elle.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la ministre.
- Jean-Claude Raux: Demain, à
11h30, à l'esplanade des
Invalides, je vous invite à venir
échanger avec les étudiants et les
étudiantes et avoir la précarité
que vous devriez combattre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
ministre?
- Sarah El Haïry: 19 millions de
repas grâce au Crous avec le repas
à un euro pour tous les jeunes qui
en avaient besoin.
Avec la ministre Sylvie
Retailleau, 10 millions
supplémentaires pour aider les
aides alimentaires et les
distributions de repas.
300.000 colis alimentaires ont été
distribués.
Le gel des logements CROUS, la
revalorisation des APL, la
revalorisation des bourses.
Des travaux sont en cours à la
table de la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur.
La jeunesse a besoin d'un pays
stable, qui lui fait confiance, et
dans lequel elle a toute sa place.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à madame Estelle
Folest.
- Estelle Folest: Merci.
Mes chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à la secrétaire d'Etat
chargée de la Citoyenneté.
Le phénomène sectaire a beaucoup
évolué ces dernières années.
Le nombre des victimes est en
constante augmentation.
Autrefois, les sectes recrutaient
dans la rue ou frappaient à votre
porte.
Elles voyaient chaque jour 10 ou
20 personnes, ce qui était déjà
trop.
Aujourd'hui, elles recrutent sur
les réseaux sociaux et touchent
des milliers de personnes par
jour.
C'est un changement d'échelle
considérable.
Ce sont souvent de petites
structures.
Elles sont plus difficiles à
identifier.
La menace est bien plus grande et
revêt d'autres visages, des
gourous 2.0, qui prennent les gens
sous emprise.
Ce sont ces guérisseurs qui
incitent leurs victimes à
abandonner leur traitement contre
le cancer au profit de jus de
légumes ou des personnes qui
vendent à prix d'or leurs conseils
de pacotille...
Face à ces nouvelles menaces, les
actions de l'Etat doivent évoluer.
Notre loi contre ces phénomènes a
plus de 20 ans, elle ne peut
répondre efficacement à ces
nouveaux enjeux.
Les assises de lutte contre les
dérives sectaires ont eu lieu il y
a quelques jours.
Quel bilan tirez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la secrétaire
d'Etat chargée de la Citoyenneté.
- Sonia Backès: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, je vous
remercie de l'intérêt que vous
portez à ce sujet qui concerne des
dizaines de milliers de nos
familles.
A travers votre question, je
remercie également toute la
représentation nationale qui a
participé au succès de ces
assises, qui ont été globalement
qualifiées de succès
par ceux qui travaillent dans
l'ombre sur ce sujet.
Il faut travailler sur des
propositions concrètes.
Vous l'avez dit, les dérives
sectaires ont évolué.
On est passés de l'église de
scientologie aux témoins de
Jéhovah que l'on connaissait bien,
à des nouvelles formes d'influence
en matière de santé, le féminin
sacré, les écovillages en
autarcie, le crudivorisme...
Nous avons fait des propositions
extrêmement fortes lors de ces
assises.
Ma collègue s'est engagée à
encadrer les pratiques
non-conventionnelles de soins.
Nous travaillons sur un plan
d'action à présenter avant l'été.
Je souhaite inviter l'ensemble de
la représentation nationale à
venir en réunion dans quelques
jours place Beauvau pour
travailler sur la mise en oeuvre
de ce plan d'action qui
travaillera sur trois grands axes:
la prévention, avec un gros
travail sur les réseaux sociaux,
un axe sur les victimes et un axe
sur la poursuite des auteurs.
Je crois que nous avons un gros
travail à mener.
Je veux remercier l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale pour le
caractère transpartisan lors de
ces assises.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Estelle Folest: Je remercie la
ministre et nous serons à ses
côtés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Béatrice Roullaud.
- Béatrice Roullaud: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre des
Solidarités.
A la veille de la Journée mondiale
de la sensibilisation à l'autisme,
voici ma question.
Les carences de la France en la
matière, et plus particulièrement
les difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontées les familles pour
scolariser leurs enfants.
L'engagement en faveur de
l'autisme devait être une priorité
du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron, et le bilan est plus que
mitigé.
Selon les chiffres du
gouvernement, sur 100.000 enfants
autistes, seulement 42.000 sont
scolarisés en milieu ordinaire et
10.000 enfants en classe ULIS.
C'est bien trop peu.
Les familles ont le sentiment
d'être abandonnées par les
pouvoirs publics, et elles
déplorent le manque de structures
adaptées.
Pour ceux qui sont scolarisés, les
accompagnants sont
indispensables à une réelle
inclusion scolaire.
Malgré un rapport accablant de la
Cour des comptes en 2018 et sept
condamnations successives de la
France pour discrimination à
l'égard des personnes autistes par
le Conseil de l'Europe, il est
regrettable de constater que
l'Etat Français n'a toujours pas
engagé de réformes d'envergure.
Certes, une maison nationale de
l'autisme va être inaugurée en
avril à Aubervilliers, mais pour
l'instant, cette structure n'est
prévue qu'en Seine-Saint-Denis.
Pourquoi ne pas la décliner dans
d'autres départements?
Permettez-moi de vous rappeler
l'article du code de l'éducation
qui explique que l'éducation est
la première priorité nationale.
Le service public de l'éducation
veille à la scolarisation
inclusive de tous les enfants sans
aucune distinction.
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir et
permettre l'efficience de cet
article?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Geneviève
Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Merci.
Vous avez raison.
Il est un fait que l'autisme et
les troubles du comportement sont
des troubles qui augmentent depuis
le début des années 2000.
Nous avons véritablement besoin
d'avoir une stratégie nationale,
ce qui a été mis en oeuvre par ce
gouvernement en 2018.
Cette stratégie, je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure, a mobilisé 550 millions
d'euros avec tout ce qu'elle a
développé.
Nous avons également mis en oeuvre
une délégation interministérielle
à l'autisme, qui structure cette
stratégie, et qui continue de
structurer, notamment tous les
dispositifs mis en oeuvre.
Cette stratégie, elle se termine,
et une autre va lui succéder.
Nous devons poursuivre nos efforts
et tout n'a pas été fait, mais
beaucoup a été fait.
De très nombreux dispositifs ont
été déployés dans les écoles pour
l'accueil des enfants autistes.
Beaucoup plus de dispositifs ont
été déployés dans l'Education
nationale.
La prise en charge existe.
Elle n'est pas suffisante au
niveau des familles.
Nous avons besoin de développer du
répit pour les familles et les
aidants.
Ca devra faire partie de la
nouvelle stratégie.
Nous avons besoin d'épauler ces
familles qui se sentent souvent
très esseulées.
Le centre d'Aubervilliers, c'est
un véritable centre de ressource
nationale qui pourra être utilisé
par chaque Français et qui sera
relayé par des plates-formes dans
chaque région.
Nous allons poursuivre nos efforts
et je vous remercie de vous
intéresser à ce sujet
particulièrement important.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Béatrice Roullaud: Nous ne
demandons qu'à vous croire, mais
les familles sont très
impatientes.
Elles m'écrivent à chaque
élection.
Ne les décevez pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Jacqueline Maquet.
- Jacqueline Maquet: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre chargé de la
Ville et du Logement.
Les Français doivent mener un
combat, un parcours du combattant
pour se loger.
Pourtant, les tensions pour
accéder au logement
risquent de s'accroire ces
prochaines années si les logements
les plus énergivores ne sont pas
rapidement rénovés.
La loi climat prévoit
l'interdiction progressive des
logements de classe G, F et E à
partir de l'année prochaine et
jusqu'en 2035.
L'année prochaine, environ 140.000
logements seront interdits à la
location.
En Hauts-de-France,
40% des
logements se situent dans ces
classes énergétiques.
Parmi les logements sociaux que
compte ma région, 27% sont
concernés.
Pour respecter nos engagements, il
sera indispensable d'accompagner
les entreprises et le secteur du
bâtiment.
Nous devrons soutenir les travaux
engagés par les propriétaires et
les copropriétaires.
A cet égard, MaPrimRenov' est un
franc succès et nous pouvons nous
féliciter d'avoir inclus son
financement dans le DLF 2023.
Les démarches effectuées
gagneraient à être plus visibles.
Nous devons accroître notre
influence et accompagner des
rénovations globales des logements
sociaux.
Nous pouvons atteindre l'objectif
de 130.000 logements rénovés par
année pour un financement de 500
millions d'euros annuels.
Quelles mesures le gouvernement
compte-t-il mettre en place pour
s'assurer que les logements sur
les marchés ne deviennent pas
vacants dans les années à venir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre en
charge du Logement.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
merci pour votre question sur ce
sujet du logement, que vous
connaissez si bien.
Oui, il est insupportable de
laisser vivre nos concitoyens dans
des logements qui sont des
passoires thermiques, voire des
taudis.
Il est insupportable que ces
personnes aient froid l'hiver.
Il est indispensable de respecter
le calendrier de rénovation pour
les passoires thermiques.
Vous avez rappelé les échéances,
dont l'interdiction d'augmenter
les loyers depuis 2022.
Il faut continuer à avoir cette
ambition.
Aujourd'hui, les propriétaires et
les bailleurs peuvent avoir
recours à MaPrimRenov'.
Il y a aussi des aides
complémentaires de réhabilitation,
l'aide aux copropriétés, et nous
devons travailler pour améliorer
les conditions des aides dans les
copropriétés...
Il faut que les logements
indécents dans une copropriété
aient accès à l'ensemble des aides
pour la copropriété.
Il y a également le prêt à taux
zéro.
Il est accessible plus facilement
aujourd'hui.
Nous avons reçu avec Christophe
Béchu les établissements bancaires
pour qu'ils soient présents à nos
côtés.
Nous allons mettre en place dès la
semaine prochaine une feuille de
route pour suivre la
réhabilitation dans l'habitat
privé pour que ce suivi soit
régulier.
Nous tiendrons nos engagements
pour que nous sortions de ces
passoires thermiques.
Oui, il est hors de question
d'augmenter le nombre de logements
vacants dans ce pays.
Il est hors de question qu'un
certain nombre de ces logements
deviennent des logements
touristiques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gabriel Amard.
- Gabriel Amard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Un consortium de journalistes
européens a établi que 17.000
sites sont contaminés par les
polluants éternels.
La représentation cartographique
indique, bien que la France est
largement impactée, des substances
de la Loire-Atlantique à la
Méditerranée, en passant par le
Rhône.
Des prélèvements montrent que les
eaux du Rhône débordent de ces
substances polluantes.
A certains endroits, on mesure des
taux plus de 3000 fois supérieurs
aux mesures de dangerosité.
Nous connaissons les problèmes que
peuvent engendrer la présence dans
le corps de ces substances:
maladies thyroïdiennes, problèmes
de fertilité, cancers...
Ces contaminations sont
principalement le fait des rejets
de deux usines, Arkema, notamment.
Rien ne les empêche de poursuivre
leur pollution.
Considérez-vous revoir votre plan
d'action afin d'agir plus vite sur
ce sujet sans attendre 2026?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Merci pour votre question qui
était sobrement intitulée
"question sur l'eau", mais qui a
un caractère plus précis, avec ces
éléments que vous évoquez.
Un plan d'action
a été rendu public en six axes.
Il vise à mieux connaître, à
identifier.
Vous pointez un élément: le
caractère éternel de cette
pollution.
Vous citez également l'enquête
complète du Monde qui vise toute
l'Europe, et pas que la France.
Les travaux de recherches se
poursuivent aujourd'hui pour
mesurer les niveaux exacts.
J'ai été saisi par un député pour
qu'une mission parlementaire
puisse creuser le sujet, sans
mauvais jeu de mots, pour regarder
s'il y a matière à réviser le plan
d'action rendu public le 17
janvier.
Nous ne sommes que fin mars.
Ce plan d'action a été déclenché
il y a deux mois et demi.
Il y a de toute façon des mesures
qui répondent par anticipation à
ces révélations.
Merci pour votre question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Amard?
- Gabriel Amard: Comment vous
croire?
Nous attendons des mesures
concrètes pour prendre le mal à la
racine.
Comment considérer que vous voulez
attaquer les problèmes, qui sont
en fait la cause de ce problème
sanitaire et climatique?
C'est ce que vous avez quand vous
allez dans le sens d'un modèle
agraire d'un autre temps?
Renoncez à ces méthodes, au lieu
de sacrifier des policiers pour
les protéger!
Préservez l'eau et le vivant!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Christophe Béchu: Ne vous
discréditez pas.
Vous menez un combat sur l'eau,
mais vous finissez par taper sur
l'image des policiers!
Vous faites semblant de
contribuer, mais vous opposez les
Français aux uns et aux autres!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Cécile
Untermaier.
- Cécile Untermaier: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la
Justice, si notre préoccupation
est centrée sur les retraites,
cela ne doit pas éclipser la
question de la lutte contre la
corruption et le maintien des
outils mis en place.
Plus que jamais, ces institutions
publiques doivent être mobilisées
contre la fraude fiscale et les
narcotrafiquants, véritables
fléaux, qui sapent les fondements
de notre démocratie et qui en
prélèvent des milliards.
Je veux parler de l'Agence
française anticorruption.
C'est le seul outil de prévention
dont le rôle a été salué grâce à
son champ de détection et de
contrôle étendu.
Elle est privée de sa commission
des sanctions depuis plus de huit
mois.
Le directeur de l'AFA, un
magistrat apprécié, entendu ici
lors des travaux que nous avons
menés sur les lanceurs d'alerte
est parti discrètement au terme de
son mandat et il n'est pas encore
remplacé.
Je m'inquiète pour la lutte contre
la corruption, pas seulement celle
des cols blancs, mais des
narcotrafiquants qui prennent la
main sur nos institutions.
Que va-t-il advenir de ce combat,
en envoyant de tels signes de
faiblesse?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre de la
Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Si vous m'y autorisez, une petite
digression, parce que je sais à
quel point vous êtes attachée au
sujet de la justice.
Souvent, nous avons travaillé
ensemble et je m'en suis toujours
infiniment réjoui.
Il y a de ça quelques heures, le
tribunal administratif de Nantes a
été de nouveau attaqué, protégé
par les forces de sécurité, et
heureusement qu'ils étaient là
pour ne pas que les choses soient
plus graves.
Le renouvellement des membres de
ce comité suppose que le Conseil
d'Etat, la Cour des comptes et la
Cour de cassation en désignent
chacun deux membres.
Nous venons d'avoir la liste de
ces membres.
Le décret sera pris dans les jours
qui viennent.
Soyez-en assurée.
Merci, madame la députée, d'avoir
rappelé à quel point l'AFA était
essentielle dans la lutte contre
la corruption.
Il est important pour nos
entreprises, pour nos entreprises,
que cette agence existe.
Le Conseil de l'Europe avait été
particulièrement élogieux sur
cette agence.
S'agissant du conseil national du
parquet national financier,
celui-ci a doublé ses effectifs en
huit ans.
Ils sont désormais assistés de 16
greffiers.
Ils ont également des juristes
assistants.
Vous devez être pleinement
rassurée.
La lutte anticorruption est au
coeur des préoccupations de la
chancellerie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une réponse?
- Cécile Untermaier: Merci.
C'était important de l'entendre
dans cet hémicycle.
Nous ne pouvons pas abandonner un
combat aussi important pour notre
démocratie.
Nous ne vous demandons pas le
retrait de la réforme des
retraites.
S'agissant de la lutte contre la
corruption, nous vous demandons
d'accélérer le combat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Fabienne
Colboc.
- Fabienne Colboc: Merci.
Je veux vous interroger sur les
écoles d'art et de design.
Elles offrent près de 8500
formations de qualité à des
étudiants dans tout le territoire.
Depuis 2010, 33 de ces écoles sont
constituées en établissements
publics de coopération culturelle.
Ils sont financés en grande partie
par les collectivités
territoriales.
Il y a une participation qui varie
en fonction des écoles.
Depuis 2022, les élèves ont peur
pour leurs écoles.
Elles sont parfois occupées, comme
à Tours.
Elles subissent, tout comme
les autres, une hausse de
l'énergie et des matières
premières.
Elles ne disposent ni du bouclier
tarifaire, ni des dotations
exceptionnelles pour supporter
cette inflation.
Je pense à la réaffirmation de la
participation de l'Etat pour ces
écoles, à l'équité de traitement
des étudiants, ou encore à la
hausse du point d'indice.
Ce sont des enjeux déjà repérés,
notamment en 2019, lorsque j'étais
co-rapporteure d'un projet de loi.
Je vous sais attachée à ces
établissements.
Qu'envisagez-vous pour répondre à
leurs besoins?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la ministre de la
Culture.
- Rima Abdul Malak: Merci.
Votre question permet de mettre en
lumière ce réseau d'écoles d'art
assez unique qui fait la
spécificité de la France.
Il y a deux types d'écoles,
lorsque l'on parle d'art.
Il y a des écoles de beaux-arts,
des établissements publics
financés uniquement par le
ministère de la Culture.
Mon ministère en a l'unique
responsabilité.
Mais il y a aussi les 33 autres
écoles d'art, comme celle de
Tours.
Historiquement, ces écoles ont été
créées à l'initiative des
collectivités.
Elles ont longtemps été gérées
ainsi.
Elles sont historiquement et
majoritairement financées par les
collectivités, à 90% à peu près.
Elles connaissent aujourd'hui des
difficultés financières en raison
de l'inflation, mais aussi en
raison de la baisse de dotation de
certaines collectivités.
Au vu de l'importance de ces
écoles, qui forment le vivier des
artistes de demain, et malgré le
fait qu'elles dépendent d'abord et
avant tout des collectivités, j'ai
souhaité engager le ministère de
la Culture pour les aider à faire
face à leurs difficultés.
A court terme, je débloque dès
aujourd'hui une enveloppe de 2
millions d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires pour faire
progresser la part de l'Etat dans
leur budget.
Ca correspond à une hausse de 14%
de leur dotation.
A long terme, vous avez soulevé un
certain nombre de défis pour ces
écoles, il va falloir s'y atteler
avec les collectivités.
J'ai confié cela à un ancien
délégué aux arts plastiques du
ministère de la Culture, une
mission, et il va nous rendre ses
préconisations avant l'été.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Jumel.
- Sébastien Jumel: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre, ce matin,
pas de poisson frais à Rungis.
Les ports sont bloqués.
Des criées sont fermées, des
marins-pêcheurs qui crient leur
colère.
C'est une grève pour ne pas
mourir.
Demain, si rien n'est fait, le
risque est grand qu'il n'y ait pas
non plus durablement de poisson
français dans nos assiettes.
Nous n'aurons plus d'artisans
pêcheurs pour les pêcher.
Plus d'artisans pêcheurs, si on
laisse les chaluts sans soutien.
Plus d'artisans pêcheurs, si on se
contente d'un projet irrespectueux
des ressources, et ignorant des
9000 marins concernés.
Plus de pêcheurs, si on ne
répartit pas mieux les quotas au
détriment des petits armements.
Plus d'artisans pêcheurs avec ce
plan en éoliens en mer.
L'Etat contrôle plus qu'il ne
protège le modèle artisanal.
Les organisations sont opaques.
Les alliances préfèrent les
bateaux hollandais, qui font ce
qu'ils veulent en Manche.
Ca déborde.
La stratégie nationale doit
changer le cap d'avenir pour les
marins-pêcheurs.
Il en va de notre souveraineté
alimentaire.
Monsieur le ministre, prenez la
barre.
L'Etat doit protéger la pêche
artisanale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au secrétaire d'Etat
chargé de la Mer.
- Hervé Berville: Le gouvernement
comprend et partage les
inquiétudes des pêcheurs.
Je partage l'exaspération et la
colère face à la proposition de la
commission, qui viserait à
interdire, pas dans 10 ans,
demain, la drague et d'autres
techniques de pêche qui sont
vitales pour l'économie de nos
territoires.
Elles ont fait la démonstration
que l'on pouvait concilier
activité économique et
préservation de l'habitat.
C'est la raison pour laquelle dès
le 8 mars, j'ai indiqué au Sénat
que la France était totalement
opposée à ce plan de la
commission, et que le président de
la République et la Première
ministre l'ont également redit au
salon de l'Agriculture.
Nous allons nous battre pour faire
en sorte qu'il ne soit pas
appliqué.
Je constate au dernier Conseil
européen que d'autres pays nous
ont rejoint.
Nous croyons en la pêche française
et en la pêche artisanale.
Nous avons défendu les pêcheurs
sur les quotas.
Pas de quotas, pas de pêche.
Au dernier Conseil européen, nous
avons réussi à défendre les
intérêts des pêcheurs français.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons prolongé par quatre fois
l'aide au carburant qui avoisine
près de 80 millions d'euros.
C'est le seul secteur qui en
bénéficie encore.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons lancé au salon de
l'Agriculture un contrat
spécifique à la filière qui vise à
moderniser la filière et à
permettre le renouvellement de la
flotte.
Il y a 20 millions d'euros qui
sont disponibles cette année pour
moderniser et changer les moteurs
de cette pêche.
Je crois en notre capacité à
surmonter les épreuves.
Il faut le faire avec beaucoup de
lucidité et beaucoup de
détermination.
Nous allons le faire
prochainement, en simplifiant la
vie des pêcheurs.
Les pêcheurs ont l'impression de
crouler parfois sous la pression.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance de questions est
terminée.